jedes Jahr pustet die Schiffahrt
weltweit eine megatonne CO2 in die Luft
das sind fast 3% der weltweiten CO2
Emissionen und damit mehr als ganz
Deutschland und Schiffe verschmutzen die
Luft manche Städte verbannen
Kreuzfahrtschiffe deshalb sogar schon
aus ihren Häfen außerdem kommt es immer
wieder zu
Ölkatastrophen aber wir brauchen die
Schiffahrt 90% aller Güter weltweit
werden auf dem Wasser transportiert dein
Laptop oder Handy auf dem du jetzt
gerade dieses Video schaust dein T-Shirt
dein Kaffee heute morgen all das wurde
wahrscheinlich irgendwann einmal per
Schiff befördert es muss sich also etwas
ändern und dafür gibt es auch eine Menge
Vorschläge Schiffe mit Hightech Segeln
efuels Luftbläschen die unter das Schiff
gepustet werden oder
highfischlck aber welche dieser Ideen
helfen uns tatsächlich genau das klären
wir heute bei dr
watsen obwohl die Emissionen von
Schiffen ein riesen Problem sind werden
sie bisher kaum reguliert nicht global
im Pariser Klimaabkommen und auch nicht
durch die EU das liegt daran dass die
internationalen Gewässer und die dort
verursachten Emissionen keinem einzelnen
Staat zugeordnet werden können und sich
dadurch niemand so richtig
verantwortlich fühlt trotzdem gibt es
mittlerweile Klimaziele für die Branche
von der International Maritime
Organization der UN dieses Jahr wurden
die so angepasst dass die Schiffahrt bis
2050 klimaneutral werden soll damit das
klappt müssten wir komplett neu denken
Schiffe müssen bald emissionsfrei
angetrieben werden im Gespräch ist hier
vieles batterieelektrisch Wasserstoff
e-fuels LNG und sogar Wind also schauen
wir uns mal die wichtigsten Kandidaten
an in den letzten Jahren hat LNG eine
steile Karriere hingelegt das ist
flüssiges Erdgas oder Liquid natural gas
dabei spart es eigentlich kaum CO2
Emissionen LNG wird bei -162 gr Celsus
verflüssigt gelagert es verbrennt
sauberer als Diesel und Öl daher
entstehen deutlich weniger Feinstaub und
Stickoxide aber trotzdem ist es ein
fossiler Rohstoff darum werden lokal nur
etwa 20% CO2 eingespart und das ist noch
ziemlich optimistisch denn die
Herstellung und Kühlung sorgen für
zusätzliche Emissionen und Erdgas
besteht vorrangig aus Methan von dem je
nach Motor etwas entweichen kann weil
Methan etwa 25 mal so schädlich ist wie
können die Klimaschäden bei der
Verwendung von Methan sogar größer sein
als bei Schweröl LNG sollte damit aus
klimagründen höchstens als
Brückentechnologie gesehen werden
nächster Kandidat Strom wie sieht es mit
der Größe und dem Gewicht der Akkus aus
in China ist im Juli ein komplett
elektrisches Frachtschiff mit Platz für
immerhin 700 Container in See gestochen
zum Vergleich das größte Frachtschiff
der Welt kann über
24000 Container transportieren die Akkus
befinden sich smarterweise in
austauschbaren Containern macht auch
Sinn aber das Schiff ist nur für eine
Strecke von etwa 1000 km ausgelegt
danach muss getauscht werden das heißt
batterieelektrisch funktioniert aber
aktuell nur für kürzere Strecken für
eine Atlantiküberquerung brauchen wir
noch andere Lösungen oder bessere
Akkutechnologie auch Wasserstoff ist
hauptsächlich für kürzere und mittlere
Strecken sinnvoll das liegt daran dass
die Tanks im Vergleich zu Schweröl
viereinhalb bis A mal so groß sein
müssten je nachdem wie stark der
Wasserstoff komprimiert wurde okay also
was ist mit längeren Strecken im
Gespräch dafür sind Methanol und
Ammoniak beides kann mittels Strom als
e-fuel hergestellt werden und auch die
Energiedichte ist ähnlich
ähnlich schlecht aber immerhin besser
als bei Wasserstoff man bräuchte etwa
zweieinhalb Mal so viel Ammoniak oder
Methanol wie Schweröl um die gleiche
Strecke zurückzulegen um weiterhin alle
Ziele zu erreichen müsste man also
zusätzlich einen extra Tankstop
einrichten oder einen Teil der Ladung
durch mehr Treibstoff ersetzen weil es
keinen Kohlenstoff enthält gibt es auch
keine lokalen CO2 Missionen bei der
Verbrennung bei der Herstellung gilt
aber wie bei allen e-fuels sind sie
ökologisch nur dann sinnvoll wenn
erneuerbarer Strom eingesetzt wird in
der Handhabung ist Ammoniak aber
ziemlich kompliziert es kann ohne
weitere Maßnahmen für feinstofbelastung
sorgen ist giftig und sowieso eine
ätzende Angelegenheit das bedeutet
spezielle Treibstofftanks neue
Belüftungssysteme und besondere
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen wenn euch hierzu also
zu grünem Amoniak ein extra Video
interessiert dann schreibt uns das gerne
mal unten in die Kommentare wir machen
gerne ein ganzes Video dazu bei methanol
ist das allerdings alles ein bisschen
leichter die feinstopbelastung ist
gering und Methanol ist biologisch
abbaubar das bedeutet selbst bei einem
Unfall wo Treibstoff Austritt besteht
kaum Gefahr für Wasserlebewesen und
genau deswegen ist Methanol ein Pferd
auf das große rädereien jetzt gerade
setzen mersk die zweitgrößte räderei der
Welt hat schon 25 dieser methanolschiffe
bestellt und rüstet alte Schiffe auf
Methanol um allerdings handelt es sich
um sogenannte dual fuel ships was cool
klingt allerdings bedeutet dass sie auch
mit fossilen Kraftstoffen betrieben
werden können je nachdem was gerade
verfügbar ist es kann also durchaus sein
dass die Dual fuel Schiffe erstmal gar
nicht mit grünem Methanol fahren sondern
mit fossilen Treibstoffen betrieben
werden dazu konnen wir allerdings keine
genaueren Infos finden das wäre auch
nicht unbedingt die Schuld der räderei
denn es gibt für grünes Methanol kaum
Lieferketten und Produktionsstätten und
dadurch taucht ein hennei Problemem auf
sich als räderei für einen und gegen
einen anderen Treibstoff zu entscheiden
ist ein großes commitment denn
Containerschiffe sind 25 bis 40 Jahre
lang in Betrieb und Umrüstungen sind
teurer als das Schiff direkt so zu bauen
das heißt wer jetzt falsch oder einfach
auch nur anders als der Rest der Branche
entscheidet wird in Zukunft von der
Konkurrenz abgehängt im Moment ist die
Frage wohin sich der Markt bewegt noch
offen und das ist ein Problem wenn sich
der riesige Markt auf viele einzelne
Treibstoffe aufteilen würde dann würde
es kompliziert und teuer werden die
Entscheidung weiter aufzuschieben geht
aber auch nicht weil die Schiffe so
lange in Betrieb sind dass sie noch
jahrzehntelang CO2 und Schadstoffe
emittieren würden für Motorenhersteller
gibt es so außerdem kaum
Planungssicherheit für die
Motorenentwicklung ein Experte fordert
deswegen sogar diese Entscheidung eben
nicht dem Markt zu überlassen sondern
dass die Staaten hier kooperieren und
sich für einen efuel entscheiden okay
cool aber es gibt noch eine Antriebsart
die komplett kostenlos ist die nichts
wiegt und fast immer verfügbar ist eine
die Menschen schon ewig nutzen wie wäre
es mit
[Musik]
Wind vielleicht hast du diese Bilder
hier schon mal gesehen das sind
sogenannte Wing sales aber wie genau
funktionieren sie normale Segel
funktionieren entweder durch Widerstand
oder durch Auftrieb Auftrieb sehen wir
sonst auch bei Flugzeugtragflächen der
Wind streicht auf einer Seite langsamer
vorbei und dadurch entsteht ein
Überdruck der das Boot nach vorne drückt
was aber nicht so ist wie bei einer
Tragfläche das Segel soll den Wind von
beiden Seiten nutzen können Segeltuch
beult sich in beide Richtungen und kann
so eine Art Kammer erzeugen bei den
soliden wingsils geht das nicht darum
muss das wingsil symmetrisch sein um
trotzdem eine Art Kammer zu erzeugen
wurde das Segel um einen zweiten Flügel
ergänzt Wind klingt erstmal sehr
nachhaltig was man aber vergisst solche
Wing sales herzustellen ist ganz schön
aufwendig eines der Wing sales vom
oceanbd Schiff soll während der gesamten
Lebensdauer von 25 Jahren etwa 1300
Tonnen CO2 Emissionen erzeugen der
größte Teil entsteht bei der Produktion
des wingses der Rest z.B durchs aus und
einklappen der Segel nach Berechnungen
von Ocean world werden diese
missemissionen aber schon nach weniger
als einem Jahr wieder eingespart auch
Wing sales werden aber nicht die Lösung
für alle Probleme sein denn die Ocean
bird wird langsamer fahren nur 10 Knoten
statt 22 wie für diesen Schiffstyp
üblich das bedeutet natürlich höhere
Kosten für die Crew und weniger Aufträge
pro Jahr und insgesamt braucht man
einfach mehr Schiffe um die gleiche
Menge an Waren zu transportieren aber
langsamer fahren ist trotzdem eine super
Idee vor allem abseits vom Segeln beim
sogenannten slow steaming wird nämlich
auch eine Menge Treibstoff gespart ein
Containerschiff spart bis zu 53% treib
Stoff wenn es nur 20% langsamer fährt
und das wiederum spart Geld und CO2 okay
zurück zum Wind der kann auch mit diesen
Segeln hier genutzt werden ja richtig
gehört das sind quasi Segel auch wenn
sie nicht so aussehen es sind Flat
naruturen und die funktionieren durch
den magnusffekt wenn sich ein drehendes
Objekt wie ein Ball oder ein Zylinder
durch die Luft bewegt wirbelt es die
Luft mit der Drehung mit die Luft bewegt
sich auf einer Seite schneller auf der
anderen langsamer und schnellere Luft
bedeutet weniger Druck ein Sog zieht das
Objekt also im rechten Winkel zur
Luftströmung nach vorne bei den
flatnarotoren dreht ein Motor die Säulen
in der entsprechenden Geschwindigkeit
aber dabei entsteht mit relativ wenig
Einsatz ein großer Vortrieb theoretisch
kann ein Schiff ausschließlich mit
diesen Rotoren fahren aber realistischer
und vielseitiger ist es andere Antriebe
damit zu ergänzen und wie viel
Treibstoff kann damit genau eingespart
werden das ist leider gar nicht so
leicht zu sagen und kommt natürlich auf
das Schiff die Route den Wind und die
Fahrgeschwindigkeit an in dieser Studie
hier wurden fletner Rotoren und solche
Kites untersucht sie zeigt dass drei
flatnarutoren über 50% der
Antriebsenergie von so einem Schiff
leisten können ein Kite kommt auf
Bestwerte von 32 bis 40%
Einsparung was aber auch super wichtig
ist ist dass die Materialien sehr leicht
sind und wie man das erreichen kann das
schaue ich mir heute hier an denn ich
bin im 3M Innovation Center in neus 3M
hat sich unter anderem darauf
spezialisiert bewährte Konzepte neu zu
denken und Lösungen für Probleme zu
finden die noch gar nicht richtig
formuliert wurden eine dieser
innovativen Lösungen von 3M zielt z.B
auf die Transportindustrie ab egal ob
Schiffe LKW oder E-Fahrzeuge Gewicht ist
immer ein limitierender Faktor um
maximal nachhaltig und wirtschaftlich zu
sein muss ein Fahrzeug daher vor allem
leicht sein hier können die sogenannten
glass bubbles von 3M einen echten
Vorteil bringen diese glass bubbles
werden als strukturelle Grundlage von
Bauteilen wie beispielsweise einer
Motorhaube verwendet und sind durch ihre
Kugelform wesentlich stabiler als
herkömmliche Füllstoffe entscheidend ist
aber dass durch die geringe Dichte
dieser winzigen glashohkugeln eine
Gewichtsreduktion von bis zu 45% möglich
ist Spritzgussteile oder faserkunststoff
verbundteile die häufig in der Industrie
verwendet werden werden so deutlich
leichter und ermöglichen dadurch dass
z.B E-Autos eine höhere Reichweite haben
falls Ihr mehr darüber erfahr wollt dann
haben wir euch in der Videobeschreibung
mit einem Link zu 3m glass bubbles und
zu ihrem deutschsprachigen YouTube-Kanal
versorgt aber jetzt geht's erstmal
weiter mit innovativen Ideen rund um das
Schiff der
Zukunft okay das war schon einige sehr
interessante Beispiele für die Zukunft
der Schiffahrt aber was werden wir jetzt
mal so richtig verrückt werden bei der
sogenannten luftschmierung werden z.B
Luftbläschen unters Schiff geblasen das
Schiff wird damit über eine Art Teppich
aus Bläs was die Reibung verringert auch
wenn sich das bisher nicht komplett
durchgesetzt hat verwenden schon einige
der größten Containerschiffe genau
dieses System außerdem gibt es spezielle
Lacke mit denen Schiffe behandelt werden
können dadurch soll die Oberfläche der
Haut von haen ähneln was besonders
hydrodynamisch sein soll allerdings sind
die Effizienzsteigerungen dadurch
schlecht belegt und mittlerweile ist es
ruhig um das Produkt geworden was
zusätzlich Treibstoff sparen könnte
größere Schiffe es klingt komisch ist
aber so wenige große Schiffe brauchen
weniger Treibstoff als mehrere kleine
allerdings wird es irgendwann auch in
den Schleusen und Häfen knnapp die
Kanäle auf die der Welthandel angewiesen
ist wurden zwar schon mehrfach
vergrößert aber die größten
Containerschiffe sind sogar für den
Panama Kanal zu groß natürlich ist auch
die Schiffsform total entscheidend die
low hanging fruits sind aber in den
letzten Jahrzehnten schon abgefrühstückt
worden nach Experteneinschätzungen sind
hier nur noch kleine Einsparungen zu
holen okay größere Schiffe langsamere
Schiffe Rotoren wingsiles und was noch
über einen Trend wollen wir hier noch
sprechen Digitalisierung und autonomis
sch Fahrt es gibt immer bessere
Computermodelle und Wetterdaten wenn
Zonen mit schlechtem Wetter einfach
umfahren werden und natürliche
Strömungen genutzt werden dann kann das
den Treibstoffverbrauch senken außerdem
kann damit die Wartezeit an Schleusen
oder Häfen verringert werden und das
wiederum schafft Kapazitäten sodass
sogar noch Verkehr von der
vollgestopften Straße aufs Wasser
verlegt werden kann nice okay und wie
kann autonomes fahren der Schiffahrt
helfen wie überall es herrscht
Fachkräftemangel mit slow steaming
braucht man sogar noch mehr Personal das
noch länger unterwegs ist selbst wenn
Schiffe nicht völlig autonom fahren
sondern von Land ferngesteuert werden
sorgt das für attraktive
Arbeitsbedingungen in der Branche also
wie sieht das Schiff der Zukunft aus
klar ist es wird ein Hybrid aus vielen
verschiedenen Technologien die wir alle
heute schon kennen und einfach nur
weiterentwickeln müssen von
flatnarotoren bis hin zu autonomen
Schiffen die Zukunft der Schiffahrt ist
vielseitig aber das stellt Redereien
auch vor Herausforderungen einen neuen
Kurs einzuschlagen oder die Segel neu zu
setzen schreibt mir gerne euren
schlechtesten lieblingswortwitz dazu in
die Kommentare bis dahin bleibt
neugierig euer Cedrick